hey 42 here some people believe you
can't hold a grudge forever
other people however are happy to not
only
hold a grudge but to build and live
inside one
for the rest of their miserable lives
these brick
and mortar grudges are known as spite
houses
properties built for the sole purpose
of annoying the neighbors as much as
humanly possible
when star wars creator george lucas
announced he was building 52 acres worth
of affordable community housing
in marin county california one of the
richest parts of the usa
people saw it as yet another example of
his well-known philanthropy but
was it only a month before his plans to
build a new film studio
in the same location were scrapped due
to local residents complaining about
increased traffic and their very
expensive views
being ruined so when the housing project
was announced
the mega rich locals were even more
appalled
claiming it would bring crime to the
area and lower property values
this inevitably led to speculation
george hadn't started the project purely
out of the goodness of his heart
but for a reason even more satisfying
than housing the needy
revenge and lucas isn't the only person
to have engaged in a spot of
architectural revenge it's unclear
exactly when spider houses
and their close relatives spite fences
first came into being but we can be sure
the concept stretches back a fair old
way
why well mostly because we human beings
can be a real bunch of dicks when we
feel like it especially to those people
closest to us
which is probably why siblings are so
well represented
in the world of spite houses take the
jealous wall for example
in the grounds of belvedere house in
mullingar
island the house was built in 1760 by
the first earl of belvedere robert
rochford after a quarrel with his
brother george
robert was so jealous of george's house
next door
he decided to build an artificial ruin
of a non-existent abbey
between the two properties the abbey
served two
purposes first it meant robert no longer
had to set eyes on his brother's
superior residence
and second his brother had to put up
with a great big pile of rubble in his
back garden
as you've probably gathered from this
little stunt
robert rochford was a bit of a git aside
from the abbey
he's mostly remembered today for locking
his wife away in one of the family homes
for more than 30 years after suspecting
her of committing adultery
but apparently karma does exist because
it's thought he was eventually murdered
by one of his many enemies another
example of spite house sibling rivalry
can be found in boston's skinny house
built sometime in the 1870s
like many spider houses the true story
of why this
ridiculously narrow home was built in
the first place
has been lost to history but according
to boston legend
two brothers inherited the land on which
to house his build from their father
just before one of them went off to
fight in the civil war
when the soldier finally made it home he
not only found
his brother had built himself a house
but
that he'd taken up almost the entire
plot leaving behind
a sliver of land roughly the size of a
nat's penis
and so out of sheer bloody mindedness
the soldier decided to build his very
own tiny house
less than three meters wide at its
narrowest point
and nine meters deep completely blocking
his brother's view
and most of the available sunlight in
the process the house is so narrow that
it's some places
an adult can touch both walls at the
same time
while standing inside but that hasn't
stopped people living there
even today the skinny house last went on
sale in 2017.
and was listed at just shy of nine
hundred thousand
dollars the skinny house is an absolute
textbook spite house
it's all about getting one up on the
other guy no matter what
even if you end up living in a stupid
impractical house
that your overweight friends can't even
fit inside
so are human beings just naturally
vindictive
well yes but then so are some animals
spite has been observed in capuchin
monkeys for example
who found ways of punishing their fellow
monkey friends
even if it means a loss of food or
resources for themselves
and what are human beings at the end of
the day
if not a bunch of angry spiteful monkeys
spite has even been studied in the
microscopic world
certain bacteria are quite happy to
release toxins
that attack and kill other bacteria even
if it leads to their own death which is
a bit more extreme than building a
spider house i suppose
but then bacteria aren't legally allowed
to own property
some researchers believe acts of spite
can even be addictive
they're mood changing consciousness
altering stress reducing
and generally make you feel better about
distressing situations
like oh i don't know being a genocidal
iraqi dictator
who's just lost a war to his biggest
rival
after saddam hussein's humiliating
defeat in the gulf war
he really threw his toys out of the pram
by having a huge mosaic flaw
in the shape of coalition leader george
bush's face
laid in an important baghdad hotel
the reason so the general public could
tread all over bush's western
imperialist
face which is considered quite a serious
insult in arab culture
when saddam's regime was toppled in 2003
however
soldiers completely removed the portrait
and replaced it
with one of saddam himself possibly
under orders of bush's son george w
who'd always had a bit of an issue with
the guy who wanted to stomp all over
daddy's nose
another common theme that crops up in
the world of spite houses
time and time again is divorce after all
few things bring out the worst in human
beings
quite like the division of a dvd
collection that was lovingly put
together
during a 20-year marriage the pink house
of plum island
is a prime example of post-marital spite
the house was built in the 20s as a
husband and wife are in the middle of
separating
but according to legend the wife would
only grant the divorce
if her husband agreed to build an exact
duplicate
of the family home for her to live in
he agreed to the outlandish request
surprisingly quickly
and the wife was soon to understand why
she'd forgotten to stipulate one thing
the location of the new home
the husband seized on the loophole
deciding to build the house
in the middle of an enormous salt marsh
where it still stands
to this day as a local icon
far from any other human life or indeed
running water
the house is plumbed with the local
utterly undrinkable
unless you want to die salt water
some studies have found that men
demonstrate higher levels of spite than
women
it's unclear exactly why but apparently
there's something in the male psyche
that makes us
a little more vindictive or as writer
gore vidal puts it
it's not enough for me to succeed others
must fail
but when women do decide to be spiteful
they can make men look like rank
amateurs
we've all heard the phrase cutting off
your nose to spite your face
and according to the 1904 book a
dictionary
of saintly women it may have its origins
with a group of 9th century nuns
nuns who were brave enough to stick two
fingers up at a group of people
most of us wouldn't dare to cross the
vikings
as viking breeders attacked the scottish
monastery of coldingham
saint abe the younger cut off her own
nose
and upper lip inspiring her fellow nuns
to do the same
in order to avoid being raped seems
extreme
right but this was a pretty legitimate
fear for a bride of christ
after all these were vikings not
chartered accountants
and extreme it may well have been but it
worked a treat
the vikings were disgusted and the nuns
chastity
remained intact unfortunately the
sexually frustrated raiders
were so disgusted they chose to burn the
disfigured nuns to death inside their
abbey
1930s property millionaire karina
cavanagh was another woman who
knew how to dish out a good spiting
despite her wealth
carvanha was looked down upon by her
fiance's family
the ancarinas a bunch of old money
aristocrats who lived in their very own
palace in buenos aires
complete with a private church they
built nearby
cavanaugh's fiancee was pressured into
calling off their engagement
so she decided to build a massive middle
finger to her
ex-potential in-laws in the shape of a
33-storey skyscraper
called the cavana building once the
tallest building in south america
right in front of their family church
psychological assessments have shown
spitefulness correlates highly
with psychopathy a personality disorder
categorized by antisocial behavior
lack of empathy and a bunch of other
unpleasant egotistical
traits all of which sound like a perfect
description of whoever came up with the
idea
of connie mac's spide fence which was
built around the sheep park baseball
stadium
in philadelphia around 90 years ago
at the time owners of houses on parts of
nearby somerset
and 20th street had a fantastic view
inside the ballpark from their rooms
so much so they were able to sell
tickets to a's fans
who weren't able to get a seat in the
stadium for games
as many as 100 people could watch from
the roof of each house
to begin with team owner and manager
connie mack
the longest serving baseball manager in
major league history
and his partner ben sheeb lets these
unofficial bleachers slide
but when their own ticket sales began to
suffer during the great depression
in the 30s they decided enough was
enough
a 10 meter fence was built completely
obscuring the view of the playing area
from nearby houses
in absolutely textbooks spite house
fashion
this unsightly erection was just as
problematic for the philadelphia a's
as it was for local residents not only
was a huge corrugated iron fence and
i saw it also made it much harder for
the team's left-handed basses to hit
home runs
and the uneven surface made it difficult
to predict bouncers in the field
blocking a sought-after view is a
popular motivator for builders of spite
houses
as was the case with the 1972
construction
of mourinho crescent in dublin this row
of 26 houses was built by local
developer charles follett
to get back at irish statesman james
caulfield
the first earl of charlemont the two had
fallen out for
reasons now lost to history but when
foliate learnt how
fonz the earl was of the view of dublin
bay from one of his favorite summer
pleasure houses
the developer gleefully obscured it
entirely
by building a nice big row of houses in
the way
incidentally number 15 mourinho crescent
would later become the birthplace of
bram stoker
author of one of the most famous novels
ever written
dracula spite houses are all about
making a point
even if doing so is enormously
inconvenient
and there's no more perfect illustration
of that
than in the proud chinese tradition of
nail houses
which take the general principles of
spite houses
and add a dash of all-out protest to the
mix
a nail house comes into being when a
homeowner refuses to sell his property
to developers looking to build things
like highways or brand new housing
complex
either because he has no intention of
moving or
because of inadequate offers of
compensation leading to
bizarre instances of houses that appear
to be in places
they definitely shouldn't smack bang in
the middle of a major road for instance
in 2001 luo beowagen and his wife
who were in their mid-60s at the time
refused to move out of their house
in eastern zhejiang province which led
to the construction company in question
simply building the road around it but
these two plucky pensioners held their
ground and photos of their now
extremely well-connected nail house went
viral
after worldwide publicity of the
farcical case
the couple eventually accepted around
forty thousand dollars in compensation
and moved out the chong king nail house
is another
famous example that hit the headlines in
when the owners yang woo and wu ping
were told their family home was due to
be demolished
to make way for a shopping mall but
yang and wu proved to be about as easy
to remove
as a red wine stain on a white carpet
they turned down compensation ignored
court orders
and steadfastly refused to move leading
to a three-year standoff
during which the construction company
not only cut off water and electricity
to the building
but also got medieval on their asses
digging
a 10-foot moat inches from the property
nevertheless yang held the fort living
in the house alone
and relying on supplies passed up by a
rope whilst wu took their story to the
press
once again the news went viral and in
the family finally relented taking up
the offer of a similar sized apartment
elsewhere in the region
although the nail house is now
demolished with the much-hated shopping
mall standing in its place
yang and wu are still seen as unwitting
folk heroes
an inspiration to other chinese people
who find themselves in similar
situations
so maybe spite can ultimately be used
for the greater good
even if that's not the driving force
behind most spite houses
after all researchers have called spite
the neglected ugly sister of
altruism and perhaps the most
heartwarming example of this
in recent times is aaron jackson's
equality house
the story of a quality house starts with
the westboro baptist church
who are very much not the kind of people
you'd associate with the term
heartwarming
in fact they aren't even a real church
the actual baptist don't want anything
to do with them
which isn't surprising because the
westboro baptist church
is attended by a group of particularly
hateful individuals
probably best known for their ongoing
campaign against the lgbt community
although they also aren't too fond of
atheists
jews muslims many other christians
and basically anyone else who isn't one
of their 70 odd members
of their douchebag cult this general
scummy behavior
inspired jackson and his charity
planting piece
to buy a house across the street from
the fake church's compound
which they proceeded to paint in the
rainbow colours of the pride flag
over the years jackson has held a
variety of protests and events
in what became known as a quality house
including a drag show a gay wedding and
even
a mock wedding between dumbledore and
gandalf
i don't envy whoever has to clean the
hair out of the plughole in that
relationship
when the house next door to a quality
house went up for sale in 2016
planting peas decided to buy that too
once again giving it a multi-coloured
paint job
this time in honor of the transgender
community despite
occasional rays of hope like a quality
house
spite houses spied fences and spite
in general is mostly about good
old-fashioned
vindictiveness but as gandhi once said
an eye for an eye makes the world blind
so wouldn't it be best if we could just
let bygones be bygones and gave our
sibling
ex or neighbor a call so he could kiss
and make up
well let me leave you with this
particularly inspiring story of someone
trying to do
just that in the late 1800s american
industrialist henry frick
was forced out of a business partnership
by fellow mogul
andrew carnegie and spent the rest of
his life concocting various forms of
revenge
he even built his own spite house in new
york a larger
much grander mansion than carnegie's
purposely located nearby to upstage his
old rival
finally however in 1919 as both men were
suffering with ill health
and nearing death carnegie reached out
and sent his personal secretary to ask
frick if they could meet up
and put their differences behind them
yes
frick said after reading the letter you
can tell carnegie i'll meet him
tell him i'll see him in hell
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on
amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you